good morning hicks tuesday today's video
was going to be a silly thing about the
project for awesome fundraiser which
begins at midnight tonight but yesterday
i learned that partners in health
co-founder dr paul farmer died in his
sleep in rwanda at the age of 62. dr
farmer devoted his life to improving
healthcare access for the world's
poorest people he was a husband and a
father i am devastated for his family he
also had so many people who considered
him a friend and a mentor and i am one
of those people i don't really know what
to say so i think i'm just gonna tell
you a story in 2001 the head of usaid
one of the world's largest health aide
organizations told the u.s congress that
he opposed extending antiretroviral
therapy access to people living in
impoverished countries he said that such
an initiative would inevitably fail
because for the treatment to be
effective the medications must be taken
on a schedule and this is a quote these
people do not know what watches and
clocks are but that lie had already been
exposed because under dr farmer's
leadership partners in health helped
pioneer comprehensive hiv care including
antiretroviral therapy in profoundly
impoverished communities using a network
of community health workers pih proved
that with adequate support and
accompaniment hiv treatment could have
similar outcomes in poor countries as in
rich ones today in haiti over 12 000
people receive hiv treatment in pih
supported facilities and in sierra leone
the average monthly rate of people
returning for ongoing hiv care is over
99.9
similarly when it comes to multi-drug
resistant tuberculosis dr farmer helped
make the case that even when treatment
is expensive or logistically complicated
it is also necessary as he wrote in his
brilliant book infections and
inequalities the modern plagues
opposition to the aggressive treatment
of mdrtb in developing countries may be
justified as sensible or pragmatic but
as a policy it is tantamount to the
different valuation of human life for
those who advocate such a policy would
never accept such a death sentence
themselves of course he would be quick
to point out that he was never alone in
this work like partnership is built into
the name of partners in health and that
was at the foundation of dr farmer's
work partnerships with hospitals and
governments and philanthropists and most
of all with his fellow clinicians and
working together paul and his partners
prove the world wrong again and again
the world said we can't treat hiv in
poor communities and dr farmer said yes
we can the world said a country like
haiti can't have a world-class hospital
and dr farmer led the way to the
building of the university hospital in
marbella and the world said there's
nothing we can do about the fact that
one out of every 17 women in sierra
leone will die in pregnancy or
childbirth and dr farmer said yes there
is something we can do about it and that
is how our community came to support pih
in building a world-class maternal and
child care center at coyote government
hospital in sierra leone today child and
maternal mortality are the lowest they
have been in human history and
healthcare systems are getting stronger
even in extremely poor communities but
profound health inequities still persist
paul was never satisfied with progress
in a world of such injustice and we
shouldn't be either healthcare access
cannot wait justice cannot wait and so
his partners around the world will carry
forward his legacy i'm going to link to
a conversation i had with paul and
another pihr in november in the
doobly-doo where you can also find a
link to the project for awesome donation
page and to donate to pih directly the
last time i spoke to paul i asked him
what keeps him going in the face of it
all and i can't quote him directly but
he said something like what keeps me
going is getting to do hard work with
friends
so here's to doing hard work with
and to the light that paul farmer's life
showed all of us
hank
i'll see you on friday